[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einer sonderfolge
des bücher podcast der faz diesmal aus
dem freien deutschen hochstift in
frankfurt am 28 september waren dort
christian brückner und tilman
spreckelsen zu gast diesmal an einem
abend für wilhelm hauff
[Musik]
ja herzlichen dank einsam und herren der
junge schwabe der im sommer 1826
norddeutschland bereiste fand dort eine
freundliche aufnahme
er wurde zu gesellschaften eingeladen
mann gab sogar gesellschaften extra für
ihn er nahm an land partien teil und
lernte in bremen eine junge frau kennen
in die er sich verliebte
das stellte sich allerdings als recht
einseitig heraus wurde aber trotzdem
rasch gesprächsthema in der hansestadt
weil der junge mann mit seiner neigung
er nicht hinter dem berg als er dann
richtung hamburg ab fuhr tat er das wohl
in dem bewusstsein sich ein wenig zum
narren gemacht zu haben
in hamburg aber entwarf wilhelm auf
einen test der leichtfüßig seine
erlebnisse spiegelte und zugleich an
einen ort versetzte der ihn tief
beeindruckt hatte den bremer ratskeller
er liefert den hintergrund für eine
geschichte die unter halten soll und das
auch tut
noch immer
und die zugleich einen abgrund erahnen
lässt aus dem sie ihr zähler ironisch
und mit fantastischen wollten
herauszuschreiben versuchte
mit dem menschen ist nicht auszukommen
sagte sie als sie in einem gasthof die
treppe hinab stiegen und ich konnte es
noch deutlich höheren jetzt will er
wieder schlafen von 9 uhr an und leben
wie ein murmeltier hätte das gedacht vor
vier jahren
sie hatten nicht unrecht die freunde
dass sie mich in unmut verließen gab es
jedoch heute abend eines der
glänzendsten
musikalischen tanzenden und deklamieren
butterbrote in der stadt und hatte sie
sich nicht alle mögliche mühe gegeben
mir dem land fremden einen angenehmen
abend dort zu verschaffen
aber es war wahrhaftig unmöglich ich
konnte nicht gehen
warum sollte ich einen tanzen t besuchen
wo sie nicht tanzte warum ein singendes
butterbrot wo ich musste es zum voraus
hätte singen müssen ohne von ihr gehört
zu werden
warum einen trauten kreis von freunden
durch trübsinn und finsteres wesen
stören
dass ich nun heute nicht verbannen
konnte gott
ich wollte ja lieber dass sie mir auf
der treppe einige sekunden fluchten als
dass sie sich von 9 uhr bis 1 uhr
langweilten wenn sie nur mit meinem
körper sich unterhielt mit bei der seele
umsonst an fragten die einige straßen
weiter auf unserer lieben frauen
kirchhof nacht wann
aber das tat mir weh dass mich die guten
gesellen für ein murmeltier hielten und
dem drang nach schlafe zu schreiben was
aus freude machen geschah
nur durch ehrliche herrmann muss dass
das mehr zu würdigen hörte ich dann
nicht wieder unten auf dem domhof sagt
ist
schlaf ist es nicht denn seine augen
leuchten aber entweder hat er wieder zu
viel oder zu wenig wein getrunken das
heißt er trinkt noch welten und alleine
der verlieh dir denn diese prophetische
kraft
oder kommt es zu ahnen dass meine augen
wacker waren weil sie heute nacht
altenrhein weilen schauen sollten
konntest du wissen dass ich gerade heute
von dem patent und erlaubnisschein vom
grate auf meine person ausgestellt
gebrauch machen werde um die rose und
eure zwölf apostel zu begrüßen
es schlug 10 uhr
hat sich die breiten stufen des
ratskellers hinabstieg
ich durfte hoffen keinen zecher mehr zu
finden denn es war werktag bei anderen
leuten und draußen holte der sturm die
windfahnen stimmten sonderbare weisen an
oder regen rauschte auf das pflaster des
domhof
der arzt die nochmals mich mit fragenden
blicken vom kopf bis zum fuß als ich ihm
die anweisung auf einigen weinen dar
so spät noch und heute in dieser nacht
rief er
mir ist es nie zu spät entgegnete ich
und nachher ist es wohl früh genug an
tage aber muss es denn
wollte eben fragen
doch sie kiel und handschrift seiner
opern vielem wieder ins auge und
schweigend aber nicht ohne zögern
schritte voraus durch die hallen
welche herz entwickelnder anblick wenn
sie ein windlicht über die lange reihe
der fässer hin streifte welche
sonderbare formen und schatten wenn es
an den schnitt bogen des kellers
zitterte und die säulen im dunklen
hintergrund wie geschäftige über um die
fässer schwebten
er wollte mir eines ihrer kleineren
gemächer aufschließen wo höchstens sechs
bis acht freunde eng zusammengerückt den
becher kreisen lassen können doch mit
trauten gesellen liebe ich ein solches
heimliches plätzchen der enge raum
drängt man an man und die töne die hier
nicht verhallen können klingen traurig
aber
allein und einsam liebig freier räume wo
der gedanke gleich den atemzügen sich
freier ausdehnt
ich wählte einen alten gewölbten saal
den größten in diesen unterirdischen
räumen zu meinem einsammeln frage
erwarten sie gesellschaft fragte der
mann an meiner seite
ich bin
sie könnten um gebeten welche haben
setzte hinzu indem er sich schon nach
den schatten um saadi seine lampe war
meinte er das fragte ich verwundert
ich meinte nur so
antwortete er indem er einige kerzen
anzündete und einen großen römer vor
mich hin setzte man spricht manchmal vom
erster september der herr senator de
waren übrigens schon vor zwei stunden da
und ich erwartete sie nicht mehr
der herr senator de warum fragte er nach
mir
naja hieß mich nur die proben heraus
nehmen
welche proben mein freund
nun die von denen 2000 und der rose
erwiderte der alte mann in dem er
anziehen einige niedliche fläschchen mit
langen papierstreifen an den hälsen
hervorzuziehen
wie riesig man sagte mir ja ich könnte
den wein von den fesseln selbst trinken
ja aber nur im beisein eines herrn vom
senat darum hieß mich der herr doktor
die zonen pröbchen herausnehmen und so
will ich sie ihnen einschenken wenn es
gefährlich
nicht einen tropfen unterbrach ich ihn
hier kein glas voll nein das ist der
echte genuss vom fass zu trinken und ist
es mir nicht mehr möglich so will ich
doch am fasse trinken kommt alter nimmt
die proben mit ich will das nicht tragen
ich stand schon einige minuten unser dem
wunderlichen treiben des alten dieners
zu bands standen still sauer auf mich
und räuspert asias wollte er sprechen
bald nur mehr die proben vom tisch und
packte sie in seine weiten tasche bald
nahm er sie zögernd wieder heraus um sie
auf den tisch zu setzen
ermüdete
michna sollen wir bald gehen rief ich
voll sehnsucht nach dem apostel keller
wie lange wollt ihr noch ein gläschen
hieraus und einpacken
der ernste ton in welchem ich dies sagte
schien ihm mut zu machen
ziemlich bestimmt antwortete er es geht
nicht mehr heute geht es nicht mehr herr
ich glaube hier in einem jener
gewöhnlichen kniffe zu sehen womit
hausverwalter castellano oder
kellermeister dem fremden geld
abzuzwacken suchen drückte ihm ein
hinlänglich das geldstück in die hand
und nahm ihn beim armin ford zu ziehen
nein so war es nicht gemeint
entgegnete er indem er das gerät stücke
zurückzuschieben suchte so nicht fremd
ich bin es nur geradeheraus sagen mich
bringt man nicht mehr in den apostel
keller in dieser nacht denn wir
schreiben heute den ersten september
und welche tor hat wollte er daraus
folgern nun
in gottes namen suchen denken davon was
sie wollen es ist dort nicht geheuer in
dieser nacht das macht es ist der
jahrestag der rose
ich lachte dass die halle dröhnte nein
in meinem leben richtung so manchen
spruch erzählen gehört aber einen
weinstock nie kennt ihr euch nicht mit
euren weißen haaren noch solches zeug zu
schwatzen
doch hier ist nicht lange zu spaßen hier
ist die vollmacht des senats im keller
da sich trinken heute nacht ohne nach
zeit und raum zu fragen
darum im namen des rates heiß ich euch
folgen schließe den keller des paris auf
so beginnt wilhelm hauffs kleine
erzählung fantasien im bremer ratskeller
untertitel ein herbst geschenk für
freunde des weines sie ist ganz
untypisch für das bild das wir
gewöhnlich vom werk dieses
schriftstellers haben den wir gerne auf
den märchen auto reduzieren auf den
schöpfer des kleinen muck zwerg nase die
geschichte von gespenster schiff oder
die sorge vom hirsch kunden
dass er einen wachen blick auf seine
umgebung hatte dass er den politischen
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
umwelt sondern der biedermeierzeit
aufmerksam registrierte soll heute abend
deutlich werden aber auch wie dieses
diagnostische russen seine auf den
ersten blick des zeitlosen texte wie
eben seine märchen prägte
und wie ihnen das problem der
unterdrückten freiheit vor allem der
redefreiheit ebenso beschäftigt wie das
der anbrechenden industrialisierung der
umwälzung der kompletten arbeitswelt in
dieser zeit
vor allem aber ist aufs blick auf seine
zeit immer auch eine auf die literatur
seinerzeit etwa
wenn er in einer reihe von kleinen
artikeln die leihbücherei aus denjenigen
ort schildert an dem sich die
tatsächliche mentalität seiner mitbürger
am besten abbildet es geht um die
vielzitierte lesegut dass der
biedermeierzeit und es geht am beispiel
eines englischen erfolgsautors um die
frage welche verbindung
industrialisierung und literarischen
moden miteinander eingehen auf findet
darauf eine prägnante antwort
der große unbekannte
ein bedienter unterbrach uns die frau
gräfin von langsdorff lässt sich ein
buch aus bitten sprache
was für eine nummer das ratio nicht
gesagt aber ich glaube sie will eine
geistergeschichte
geistergeschichte fragte der kleine
bibliothekar umher suchen
das ist auch eine ritter geschichte sein
die geister sind alle ausgeliehen
ja nur etwas rechtlich ist das hat sie
gerne erwiderte der diener sowie das
letzten die schwarzen ruinen oder das
unterirdische gefängnis das hat uns sehr
gut gefallen
ist er denn auch mit sagte der kleine
mann mit staunen
nachher wenn die frau gräfin einen band
durch hat ließen wir es auch im
bedingten zimmer
gute
will er lieber das geisterschloss
die auferstehung im toten gebirge oder
das feurige erschwert von hildebrand
da tut mir die wahl wie wieder der was
müssen das für schöne bücher seien nun
ich will diesmal das feurige rachel
schwer team behalten sie mir das
geisterschloss für das nächste mal
[Musik]
aufbauen hatte sich der diener der
gräfin die gerne schauergeschichten las
entfernt so trat gemessenen schrittes
ein soldat ein
für den herrn
juncker beim fünfzehnten regiment in
blinden torwart vom alten shop
freund hat er auch recht gehört fragte
der leihbibliothek den
blinden torwart vom alten schrott ich
kenne keinen autor dieses namens
es soll auch kein autor sein entgegnete
der soldat vom 15 sondern ein buch der
herr ordnung sind auf der wache und
wollen lesen
wohl aber vom alten schrott es steht
weder ein alter noch ein junger im
katalog
es ist glaube ich derselbe der so viel
gedruckt hat und den sich alle korporal
so und wachtmeister um zwei gute
groschen gekauft haben
weiters kommt rief der kleine mit lachen
und das buch wird könnten gerhard heißen
ach so oder so wird es heißen sprach der
so tat aber ich darf den hamilton nicht
zweimal fragen sonst hätte ich wohl den
namen gemerkt und er hat sich das
undeutliche sprechen vom kommandieren an
gewünscht
er empfing seinen blinden torwart und
ging
aber der himmel hatte ihnen in diesem
augenblick in die leihbibliothek gesandt
und seine leute hatten einen lichtstrahl
in meiner seele geworfen
so ist es denn war sprach ich dass die
werke dieses briten beinahe so
verbreitet sind als die bibel dass alt
und jung und selbst die niedrigsten
stände von ihm bezaubert sind
gewiss man kann rechnen dass allein in
deutschland
60.000 exemplare verbreitet sind und er
wird täglich noch berühmter in china hat
man jetzt eine eigene übersetzung fabrik
angelegt wo täglich 15 bogen übersetzt
und so leicht gedruckt werden
wie ist das möglich
es scheint beinahe unmöglich als das
wort scott diese reihe von wänden in so
kurzer zeit sollte geschrieben haben
aber es ist so denn erst vor kurzer zeit
hat er sich öffentlich als autor bekannt
die fabrik habe ich aber selbst gesehen
wird vielleicht durch verteilung der
arbeitszeit gewonnen fragte ich
einmal dies entgegnete er und sodann
wird alles mechanisch betrieben der
professor lux ist sogar gegenwärtig
beschäftigt eine dampfmaschine zu
erfinden die französisch englisch und
deutsch versteht dann braucht man gar
keine menschen mehr
die fabrik ist aber folgendermaßen
beschaffen hinten im hof ist die
papiermühle welche
unendliches papier macht das schon
getrocknet wie ein lavastrom das
erdgeschoss des hauptgebäudes herr
überrollt dort wird es durch einen
mechanismus in bogen zerschnitten und in
der druckerei bis unter die pressen
geschoben
15 pressen sind im gang wovon jede
täglich 20.000 abdrücke macht nebenan
ist der trockenen platz und die
buchbinder hält städte man hat berechnet
dass der papierbrei welcher morgens 5
uhr noch schließlich ist in anderen
morgen um 11 uhr also innerhalb 30
stunden ein elegantes büchlein wird
im ersten stock ist die übersetzungs
anstalt man kommt zuerst in zwei säle in
jedem derselben arbeiten 15 menschen
jedem wird morgens 8 uhr ein halber
bogen von scott vorgelegt welchen er bis
mittag 3 uhr übersetzt haben muss das
nennt man dort aus dem groben arbeiten
15 bogen werden auf diese art jeden
morgen übersetzt um 3 uhr bekommen diese
leute ein gutes mittags rund um 4 uhr
wird heben wieder ein halber bogen
gedruckte übersetzung vorgelegt die
durchgesehen und korrigiert werden muss
aber was geschieht dann mit dem
übersetzten bogen vom vormittag
wir werden zugleich sehen
an die zwei säle stoßen vier kleine
zimmer
in jedem sitzt ein stilist und sein
sekretär stilisten nennt man dort
nämlich diejenigen welche die
übersetzungen der dreißig durchgehen und
aus dem groben ins feine arbeiten sie
haben das amt in stil zu verbessern
ein solcher stil ist verdient täglich
zwei taler muss aber seinen sekretär
davon bezahlen die sieben bis acht grob
arbeiter sind einem stilisten zugeteilt
sobald sie eine seite geschrieben haben
wird sie den stilisten geschickt er hat
das englische exemplar in der hand lässt
sich vom sekretär des übersetzers
vorlesen und verbessert hier und dort
die perioden in einem fünften zimmer
sind zwei poetische arbeiter welche die
mottos über den kapiteln und die im text
vorkommen um gedichte in deutscher
übersetzung
ich staunte über diesen wunderbaren
mechanismus und bedauerte nur dass die
30 arbeiter und vier stilisten notwendig
ihr brot verlieren müssten wenn der
professor lux die übersetzungs maschine
erfindet
gott weiß wie es dann gehen wird
antwortete der kleine mann schon jetzt
kostet das bändchen in der schuhfabrik
nur einen groschen in
zukunft wird man zwei bändchen um einen
silbergroschen geben und alle vier tage
wird eines erscheinen
das ist nicht nur satire es ist auch ein
zerrspiegel seiner eigenen literarischen
tätigkeit und damit eine warnung
gerichtet an sich selbst den
literarischen unternehmer auf
erstaunlich früh findet auf eine
konsequente linie für die es in
deutschland keine vorläufer gibt er
etabliert den typus des berufs
schriftstellers mit einer solchen
zielstrebigkeit dass man ihm ein
visionäres bewusstsein für die
möglichkeiten bescheinigen muss die mit
den revolutionären technischen und
gesellschaftlichen umwälzungen sein zeit
verbunden sind
den literarischen markt der sich in
deutschland gerade entwickelt nutzt er
mit einem sicheren gespür für modische
themen und publikationsformen und weil
er es außerdem versteht die
verschiedenen verlagshäuser
gegeneinander auszuspielen
lieber sei es ihm schreibt er einmal in
fünf zeitschriften mit einem beitrag
vertreten zu sein als in einer
zeitschrift mit 5 ist er bald nicht nur
ein erfolgreicher sondern auch ein sehr
gut bezahlter autor der außerdem noch
als hauslehrer und zeitungsredakteur
wirkte und einer dissertation abschloss
als er 1827 starb war er keine 25 jahre
alt in den knapp drei jahren zuvor
erschienen so viele literarische texte
dass sie in der ersten werkausgabe von
1830 stattliche 36 bändchen füllten
darunter ist natürlich ein historischer
roman namens liechtenstein aber er setzt
sich auch satirisch mit der literatur
seiner zeit als einander der mann im
mond oder der zug des herzens ist des
schicksals stimme eine parodie auf die
stolzen romane jenes berliner hofrats
karl heim der seine werke mit dem
anagramm hark lauren unterzeichnete um
das ziel seiner satire deutlich zu
markieren wählte auf genau dasselbe
pseudonym so zumindest stellte als
später da es zu einer klage des empörten
gegen hauf und seinen verleger frank kam
wahrscheinlich spannende entscheidung
für das etablierte gaga nun aber auch
das doppelte kalkül mit sich den erfolg
lauriens zunutze zu machen und
gleichzeitig durch den erwartbaren
skandal bekannt zu werden
im schatten von der mann im mond stand
aufs anderes fast gleichzeitig und im
selben verlag erschienenes buch
mitteilungen aus den memoiren des satans
ein erstes beispiel voraus auffälliges
interesse
in einer vielfach gebrochenen
erzählperspektive
das buch versammelt binnen geschichten
die gerne unterbrochen und später
fortgesetzt werden reflektierende
passagen und eine einleitungen er ein
namenloser herausgeber von seinem
zusammentreffen mit dem satan berichtet
das thema des erkennens das wenig später
im haus märchen einmal nach soll es eine
übermächtige rolle spielen wird ist auch
hier von bedeutung
als sich der satan einem gasthof
einquartiert meint jeder der übrigen
dass der ihn schon einmal gesehen zu
haben allerdings bringt jeder ihn mit
einer anderen person in verbindung
der professor nahm eine prise
klopfte den abo aus und begann
zu mögen nun ungefähr zwölf jahre sein
als ich wegen eines prozesses einige
monate in stuttgart zu brachte
ich wohnte in einem der ersten gasthöfe
und schweißt auch dort gewöhnlich in
großer gesellschaft an der wirt staffel
einmal kam ich nach einigen tagen in
welch nicht das zimmer hätte hüten
müssen zum ersten mal wieder zu tisch
man sprach sehr eifrig über einen
gewissen herrn buggy der seit einiger
zeit die mittagsgäste durch seinen
lebhaften witz durch seine gewandtheit
in allen sprachen entzücken
in seinem lob waren alle einstimmig nur
über seinen charakter war man nicht
recht einig denn die eigenen macht ihn
zum diplomaten die anderen zu einem
sprach meister die dritten zu einem
hohen verwandten wieder andere zu einem
spion
die tür ging auf mann war still beinahe
verlegen den streit so laut geführt zu
haben ich merkte dass der besprochenen
sich eingefunden habe und sie nun
ich bitte sie denselben der uns
den reden der uns seit einigen tagen so
trefflich unterhält
das wäre übrigens gerade nichts
übernatürliches aber hören sie weiter
zwei tage schon hatte uns herr barroso
nannte sich der fremde durch seine
geistreiche unterhaltung die tafel
gewürzt
als uns einmal der wirt des gasthofs
unterbrach
man herrn
sagte der höfliche bereiten sie sich auf
eine köstliche unterhaltung die ihnen
heute morgen zuteil werden wird vor der
herr ober justizrat hasen treffer zog
heute aus und zieht morgen ein
wir fragten was dies zu bedeuten habe
und ein alter grauer hauptmann der schon
seit vielen jahren den obersten platz in
diesem gasthof behauptete teilte uns den
schwank mit
gerade im speisesaal gegenüber wohnt ein
alter junggeselle einsam in einem großen
haus er ist ober justizrat außer dienst
lebt von einer anständigen pension und
soll überdies ein enormes vermögen
bereits
derselbe ist aber ein kompletter name
und hat ganz eigene gewohnheiten wie zum
beispiel dass er sich selbst oft große
gesellschaft gibt wobei es immer flott
hergeht er lässt 12 kuverts aus dem
wirtshaus kommen feine weine hat er im
keller und eine oder andere unserer
marke hat die irre zu sehr ihren
mann denkt vielleicht er hat allerlei
hungrige oder durstige menschen dass ich
mitnichten
alte gelbe stammbuch blätter auf jedem
ein großes kreuz liegen auf den stühlen
dem alten kauz ist aber sowohl als wenn
er unter den lustigsten kamran wäre es
spricht und lacht mit ihnen
und das dem so greulich
anzusehen seien dass man immer die neuen
kellner dazu braucht denn wer einmal bei
einem solchen zug ii war geht nicht
wieder in das haus
vorgestern war wieder ein super und
unser neuer frank schwerdt himmel und
erde ihn bringe keine seele mehr über
den anderen tag nach dem gast mal kommt
dann die zweite sonderbar kite des ober
justizrat er fährt morgens früh aus der
stadt und kehrt erst den anderen morgen
zurück nicht aber in sein haus das um
diese zeit fest verriegelt und
verschlossen ist sondern hierher ins
wirtshaus
da tut er dann ganz fremd gegen leute
welche das ganze ja täglich sieht speist
zu mittag und stellt sich nachher an ein
fenster
und betrachtet sein haus gegenüber von
oben bis unten
wem gehört das haus da drüben fragt er
dann erlischt
pflicht mäßig bückt sich dieser jedesmal
und antwortet dem herrn oder justizrat
hasen treffer exzellenz aufzuwarten
aber er professor wie hängt denn ihr
toller hasen treffer mit unserem naters
zusammen fragte ich
blieben sie sich doch zu dulden der
doktor antwortete jener es wird ihnen
gleich ein licht aufgehen der hasen tv
geschaut also das haus und erfährt dass
bis dem hasen treffer gehöre
derselbe den tübingen zu meiner zeit
studierte fragt er dann reißt das
fenster auf streckt den gepuderten kopf
gegen haut und haaren
wm-treffer
natürlich antwortet niemand er aber sagt
dann der alte wo das mini vergessen wenn
ich nicht bei ihm einkehrte nimmt hut
und stock schließt sein eigenes haus auf
und so geht es nach wie vor
wir alle wurde professor in seiner
erzählung fort waren sehr erstaunt über
diese sonderbare erscheinung und freuten
uns königlich auf den morgen den spaß
herberge aber nahm uns das versprechen
ab ihnen nicht verraten zu wollen in
denen er einen köstlichen scherz mit dem
ober justizrat vor habe
früher als gewöhnlich versammelten wir
uns an der wirtschaft und belagerten die
fenster eine alte baufällige scheessel
wurde von zwei alten klettern die straße
herangeschleppt sie hielt vor dem
wirtshaus das ist der hasen treffer der
hasen treffer tönte es vom aller mund
und eine ganz besondere fröhlichkeit
bemächtigte sich unser als wir das
männlein ziemlich gepudert mit einem
stall grauen rock line angetan ein
mächtiges mehr rohr in der hand
aussteigen sah
einen schwanz von mindestens zehn
kellnern schloss sich ihm an so gelangte
er in das speisezimmer
man schritt sogleich zur tafel hin
ich habe selten so viel gelacht als
damals denn mit der größten
kaltblütigkeit
behauptete der alte geraden weges aus
kassel zu kommen und vor sechs tagen in
frankfurt im schwanen recht gut los hier
zu haben
schon vor dem dessert muss dabei
verschwunden sein denn als der ober
justizrat aufstand und sich auch die
übrigen gäste erwartungsvoll erhoben war
er nirgends zu sehen
der ober justiz hat stellte sie als
fenster
wir alle folgten seinem beispiel und
beobachteten ihn
das haus gegenüber
schiene und unbewohnt
auf der türschwelle sprosse gras die
jalousien waren geschlossen zwischen
einigen schienen sich vögel eingebaut zu
haben
da drüben begann der alte zudem wird der
immer in der dritten stellung hinter ihm
stand wem gehört es
dem oberhaus die tat hasen treffer
exzellenz aufzuwarten
das ist oder nämlich mit dem ich
studiert habe liefe aus der würde es mir
nie verzeihen wenn ich ihm nicht meine
anwesen hat konnte er
ist das fenster auf
asl treffer h sind treffen
mit heiserer stimme hinaus
aber wer beschreibt uns uns schrecken
uns gegenüber in dem haus das wir wohl
verschlossen und verriegelt husten ein
fensterladen langsam sich öffnete ein
fenster tat sich auf und heraus schaute
der ober justizrat hasen treffer im
sitzenden schlafrock unter weißen mütze
unter welcher wenige graue löckchen
hervorholen so
gerade so pflegte er sich zu hause zu
tragen
bis auf das kleinste feld ziehen das
bleichen gesichts war der gegenüber der
nähe ich hier wieder der bei uns stand
aber entsetzt wieder griff uns als der
im schlaf auch mit derselben heiseren
stimme über die straße herüber rief was
will man leben ruft man
sind sie der herr ober justizrat hasen
treffer
brief der auf unserer seite gleich
wieder tod mit zitternder stimme
indem er sich beben am fenster hier
der bin ich gereift er jene und nickte
freundlich grinsend mit dem kopf steht
etwas zurück
ich bin eher ja auch rief der auf
unserer seite wehmütig wie ist denn dies
möglich
sie ehren sich wertes
darüber sie sind der dreizehnte kommen
sie nur ein wenig darüber in meiner
behausung dass ich ihnen den hals
umdrehen es tut nicht weh
kerner stock und hut rief der ober
justizrat bis zum tod und die stimme ich
ihm einen kläglichen tönen aus der
hohlen brust darauf in meinem haus ist
da sagt haben viel meine seele
vergnügten abend meine herren setzte er
hinzu
indem er sich mit dem freundlichen
bedingt zu uns wandte und dann den saal
verließ
was war das fragten wir uns sind alle
wahnsinnig
der im schlafrock schaute noch immer
ganz ruhig zum fenster hinaus während
unser gutes altes
bisschen in steifen schritten über die
straße stieg
an der haustür zu keinen großen
schlüsselbund aus der tasche
regelte
der im schlafsaal ganz gleichgültig zu
regelte die schwere knarrende haustür
auf und trat ein
jetzt zog sich auch der andere vom
fenster zurück man sah wie dem unsrigen
an die zimmertüre entgegenging
unser wird die zehn kellner waren alle
gleich von entsetzen und zitaten meine
helm sollte ich ihnen gott zu dem armen
hasen treff erledigten einer von beiden
war der leibhaftige
wenn sie sich jemals gefragt habe woher
die idee von dinner for one stammt dann
kennen sie jetzt die antwort
das verwirrspiel der identitäten ist
nicht ohne grund ein zentrales motiv
biedermeierliche literatur die
kollektive identitätskrise jener zeit
die aufs engste mit den verunsicherungen
der tiefgreifenden technischen
wirtschaftlichen sozialen und
politischen umbrüchen zusammenhängt
bricht sich in der zeitgenössischen
literatur mit einer unzahl von
doppelgänger verwechslung ist
vertauschung oder verkennung geschichten
baden hauffs märchen einmal nachspielen
das thema fortwährend durch der berühmte
kalif storch wird in ein tier verwandelt
ein hübscher junge in einen hässlichen
zwerg nase der scheich von alexandria
und sein vor vier jahren entführten sohn
erkennen einander erst nach vielen
stunden des erzählens der räuber europa
sahen täuscht gar eine ganze
reisegesellschaft über seine identität
während in doppelter verkennung der
junge handwerker felix mit der
gefangenen griffen die kleider tauscht
ohne zu wissen dass er als sozialer
patentante zu tun hat
in diesem verwechslungen die mal
komödiantischen mal tragischen charakter
haben klingt immer wieder die auflösung
der persönlichkeit in unterschiedlichen
rollen an
was etwa erziehung in dieser hinsicht
vermag zeigt die satirische iv
erkennungs geschichte der afx als mensch
ein fremder herbst in eine deutsche
kleinstadt ein und bringt einen besucher
mit der schon bald das beschauliche
gemeinwesen nachhaltig in den bann
schlägt
[Musik]
es war schon nacht als der fremde herr
wieder im wagen vor dem tor an kam
es aber noch eine person im wagen die
den hut tief ins gesicht gedrückt und um
mund und ohren ein solches tuch gebunden
hatte der torschrei behielt es für seine
pflicht dem anderen fremden an zu reden
und seinen pass zu bieten aber er
antwortete sehr grob indem er in einer
ganz unverständlichen sprache brummte er
ist mein neffe sagte der fremde mann
freundlich zum tor schreiber in dem er
ihm einige silbermünzen in die hand
drückte er ist mein neffe und steht bis
dato noch wenig deutsch er zu eben in
seiner mundart ein wenig geflucht was
wir hier aufgehalten werden
einen eher theron ist
antwortete der tor schreiber so kann
auch wohl ohne pass hereinkommen wird
wohl ohne zweifel bei ihnen um
allerdings sagte der fremde und hält
sich wahrscheinlich längere zeit hier
auf
der tour schreiber hatte könne weitere
einwendungen mehr unter fremde herde und
sein neffe fuhren ins städtchen
der bürgermeister und die ganze stadt
war übrigens nicht sehr zufrieden mit
dem tor schreiber erhält doch wenigstens
einige worte von der sprache des neffen
sich merken sollen daraus hätte man dann
leicht erfahren was für ein landeskind
er und der herr onkel wäre
der thor schreiber versicherte aber dass
es wieder französischer italienischer
wohl aber habe es so breit geklungen wie
englisch und wenn er nicht so habe der
junge herr gesagt gott denn
so als der tor schreiber sich selbst aus
der not und dem jungen mann zu einem
namen denn man sprach jetzt nur von dem
jungen engländer im städtchen
aber auch der junge engländer wurde
nicht sichtbar wird auf der kugelbahn
noch im bierkeller wohl aber gab er den
leuten auf andere weise viel zu schaffen
es begann sich nämlich dass in dem sonst
so stillen haus des fremden ein
schreckliches geschrei und ein lärm
ausging dass die leute haufenweise vor
dem hause stehen blieben und hinauf
sahen man sah dann den jungen engländer
angetan mit einem roten frack und grünen
beiden kleidern mit struppigem haar und
schrecklich amine
unglaublich schnell an den fenstern hin
und her durch alle zimmer laufen der
alte fremde lief ihm in einem roten
schlafrock eine hetz peitsche in der
hand nach verfehlte ihn ost aber einige
male kam es doch der menge auf der
straße vor als müsse er den jungen
erreicht haben denn man hörte klägliche
angst töne und klatschende
peitschenhiebe die menge
an dieser grausamen behandlung des
fremden jungen mannes nahmen die frauen
des städtchens so lebhaften anteil dass
sie endlich den bürgermeister bewegten
einen schritt in der sache zu tun er
schrieb dem fremden montiert worin er
ihm die unglückliche behandlung seines
neffen im ziemlich derben ausdrücken
vorwarf und ihm drohte wenn er noch
ferner solche szenen vorspiele den
jungen mann und das einen ganz
besonderen schutz zu nehmen
wer aber war mehrere stand als der
bürgermeister wir den fremden selbst zum
ersten mal seit zehn jahren bei sich
eintreten sagt
der alte herr entschuldigte sein
verfahren mit dem besonderen auftrag der
eltern des jungen links die ihm solchen
zu erziehen gegeben er sei sonst ein
kluger anständiger junge
äußerte er aber die sprache erlernen er
sehr schweren er wünschte so sehen sich
seinem neffen das deutsche recht
geläufig beizubringen um sich nachher
die freiheit zu nehmen ihn in die
gesellschaft von grünen wiesen
einzuführen und dennoch gehe demselben
diese sprache so schwer ein dass man oft
nichts besseres tun können als ihm
gehörig durchzupeitschen
der bürgermeister fand sich durch diese
mitteilung völlig befriedigt mit dem
alten zur mäßigung und zählte abends im
kerker dass er selten einen so
unterrichteten artigen mann gefunden als
den fremden es ist nur schade setzte er
hinzu dass er so wenig in gesellschaft
kommt
ich denke wenn der neffe nur erst ein
wenig deutsch spricht besucht meine
schwestern
durch diesen einzigen vorfall
war die meinung des städtchens völlig
umgeändert man hielt den fremden für
einen artigen man sehnte sich nach
seiner näheren bekanntschaft und fand
das ganze in der ordnung wenn hier und
da in dem öden hause ein grässliches
geschrei aufging
gibt im neffen unterricht in der
deutschen sprach nähere sagten die
grünen wiesen und blieben nicht mehr
stehen
nach einem vierteljahr ungefähr stehen
der unterricht im deutschen beendigt
denn der alte ging jetzt um eine stufe
weiter vor es liebte ein alter
gebrechlicher franzose in der stadt der
den jungen leuten unterricht im tanzen
gaben diesen ließ der fremde zu sich
rufen und sagte ihm dass er seinen
neffen im tanzen unterrichten lassen
wolle er gab ihm zu verstehen dass
derselbe zwar sehr gelehrig aber was das
tanzen betreffe etwas eigentlich sei er
habe nämlich frühjahr bei einem anderen
meister tanzen gelernt und zwar nach so
sonderbaren touren dass er sich nicht
glücklich in der gesellschaft
produzieren können der neffe halte sich
aber eben deswegen für einen großen
tänze obgleich sein tanz sich die
entfernteste ähnlichkeit mit falscher
oder galopp tänze die man in meinem
vater lander tanzt nicht einmal
ähnlichkeit mit egos oder vom ses habe
er versprach übrigens einen taler für
die stunden und der tanzmeister war mit
vergnügen bereiten unterricht des
eigenwilligen zöglings zu übernehmen
es gab wie der franzose unter hand für
sich hatte auf der welt nichts
sonderbares als diese tanzform
der neffe ein ziemlich großer schlanker
junger mann der nur etwas sehr kurze
beine hatte
erschien in einem roten lackschuh
frisiert in grünen weiten kleidern und
lancieren handschuhen er sprach wenig
und mit fremdem akzent war von anfang
ziemlich artig und anständig dann für
viele aber oft plötzlich in fratzenhafte
sprünge tanzte die kühnsten touren wobei
er antritt machte das dem tanzmeister
hören und sehen verging wollt ihr ihn
zurechtweisen so zog die zierlichen tanz
schuhe von den füßen warf sie dem
franzosen an den kopf und setzten nun
auf allen vieren im zimmer umher
als aber der tanzmeister seinen zögling
so weit gebracht hatte
dass man musik zu der stunde nehmen
konnte da war der neffe wie umgewandelt
ein stadtmusik hand war gemietet der im
saal des alten hauses auf einen tisch
setzen musste der tanzmeister stellte
dann die dame vor
indem in der alte herr 1 frauen rock von
seide und einen ostindischen schal
anziehen ließ
den fc forderte ihn auf und fing nun an
mit ihm zu tanzen zu walzen
er war aber ein
unermüdlicher rasen der tänzer ließ den
meister nicht aus einer langen armen ob
er echte und schrie er muss der tanzen
bis er ermattet um st oder bis dem stadt
musikus der arm nahm wurde an der geige
der tanzmeister brachte diese
unterrichtsstunden beinahe unter den
boden aber der taler den er jedes mal
richtig ausbezahlt bekam der gute wein
denen der alte aufwartete machten dass
er immer wieder kam wenn er auch den tag
zuvor sich fest vorgenommen hat er nicht
mehr in das oberhaus zu gehen
die leute in grün wieso aber sahen die
sache ganz anders an als der franzose
sie fanden dass der junge mann fiel
anlage zum gesellschaftlichen habe und
die frauen zimmer im städtchen freuten
sich bei dem großen mangel an herrn
einen so flinken tänzer für den nächsten
winter zu bekommen
eines morgens
berichteten die märkte die vom märkte
heimkehrten ihren herrschaften ein
wunderbares ereignis vor dem öden hause
sei ein prächtiger glas wagen gestanden
mit schönen pferden bespannt und ein
bedienter in reicher livni habe den
schlag gehalten da sei die türe des
irrenhauses aufgegangen und zwei schön
gekleidete herren hervorgetreten wovon
der eine der alte fremde und der andere
wahrscheinlich der junge herr gewesen
der so schwer deutsch gelernt und so
rasen tanzen
die beiden seien in den wagen gestiegen
der bediente hinten aufs brett
gesprungen und der wagen man stellt sich
vor sei geradezu auf bürgermeisters haus
zu gefahren
als die frauen solches von ihren märkten
erzählen würden rissen sie eilends die
küchenschürze nur die etwas unsauberem
ab versetzten sich in staad es ist
nichts gewiss sagten sie zu ihrer
familie in dem alle umher rannten um das
besuchs- zimmer das zugleich zu
sonstigen gebrauch diente aufzurollen es
ist nichts gewisser als dass der fremde
jetzt seinen neffen in die welt einführt
der alte name war zwar seit zehn jahren
nicht so artig einen fuß in unser haus
zu setzen herausgab
seitdem ist ihm wegen seines namens
alles verziehen der ein charmanter
mensch sein soll so sprachen sie und
ermahnten ihre söhne und töchter recht
manierlich aus zusehen wenn die fremden
kämen sich gerade zu halten und sich
auch an der besseren aussprache zu
bedienen als gewöhnlich und
die klugen frauen im städtchen
hatten nicht unrecht geraten denn nach
der reihe vor der alte herr mit seinem
neffen umher sich und ihn in die
gewohnheit der familien zu empfehlen
man habe die wahl ganz erfüllt von den
beiden fremden und bedauerte nicht schon
früher diese angenehme bekanntschaft
gemacht zu haben der alte herr zeigte
sicher seinen würdigen sehr vernünftigen
mann der zwar bei allem was er sagt ein
wenig lächelte so dass man nicht gewiss
war ob es ihm ernst sei oder nicht aber
er sprach über das wetter über die
gegend das sommervergnügen auf dem
keller am berge so klug und durchdacht
dass jedermann davon bezaubert war
aber dennoch
er bezaubert alle gewannen alle herzen
für sich
man konnte zwar fast ein äußeres betraf
sein gesicht nicht schön nennen der
untere teil besonders die kinnlade stand
allzusehr hervor
und täter war sehr freundlich
auch machte er zu halten allerlei
sonderbare grimassen drückte die augen
zu und fletscht er mit den zähnen aber
dennoch fand man den schnitzeln anzüge
ungemein interessant
konnte nichts bewegendes geben nichts
beweglichere sgm anderes als seine
gestalt die kleider hängen ihm zwar
etwas sonderbar am leib aber es stand
ihm alles treffe ich erfuhr mit großer
lebendigkeit im zimmer umher warf sich
hier auf einem sofa dort in einen leeren
stuhl und streckte die beine von sich
aber was man bei einem anderen jungen
mann höchst gemein und unschädlich ist
unten galt bei dem nächsten
kriminalität
er ist ein engländer sagte mann so sind
sie alle ein engländer kann sich auf
scania belegen und einschlafen während
zehn damen keinen platz haben und umher
stehen müssen einem engländer grammatur
etwas nicht übernehmen
gegen den alten herren seine nur
hellseher fügsam
denn wenn er anfing im zimmer umher zu
hüpfen oder wir gerne tat die schüsse
auf den sessel hinauf zu ziehen
so reichte ein ernsthafter blick hin zur
ordnung zu bringen
und wie konnte man ihm so etwas
übernehmen als vollends der onkel in
jedem haus zusammen sagte man erst noch
ein wenig ruhe ungebildet aber ich
verspreche mir viel von der gesellschaft
die wirtin gehörig formen und bilden
und die empfehle in
namentlich ihnen
aus angelegentlich
auf geht allerdings nicht so weit
nachdem andere autoren zum beispiel
büchner grabe oder karl immer man meinen
ist mir verloren ruft eine figur immer
man es drama die verkleidungen aus und
formuliert damit den sack zu einer
ganzen generation
dabei behält auf sein publikum die söhne
und töchter gebildete stände an dies ist
seine märchen einmal nach explizit in
der vorrede richten fest im blick denn
das ist seine eigentliche qualität das
ist der grund warum seine märchen so
begeistert aufgenommen wurden um sich
noch heute so frisch und unmittelbar
ausnehmen oft gelingt es im gewand des
märchens die drückenden probleme des
aufkommenden industriezeitalters zu
diskutieren es ist vor allem das
wirtshaus im spessart der 1827
erschienene dritte märchen alba nach der
sich entschieden der gegenwart stellt
nicht nur das fortwährende ökonomisches
gesprochen wird bis hin zum auf und ab
der währungen in der sage vom hirsch
golden
das bekannteste märchen dieser sammlung
das kalte herz beschreibt exemplarisch
den übergang von der traditionellen
wirtschaftsform zu den strukturen der
neuen ökonomie seit der
industrialisierung
gezeigt wird sie am beispiel des kohlen
mutter eines mäßig begabten dafür vom
gesellschaftlichen ehrgeiz bessers
nennen jungen mannes aus dem schwarzwald
symbolisch für die tradition und die
moderne stehen zwei gas da das gute glas
männlein und der böse holländer michel
der nicht zufällig mit
siebenmeilenstiefeln
ausgestattet ist er verkörpert den
aufbruch in die neue zeit die
zuallererst als eroberung des raumes als
globalisierung kommt in dem er den
üblichen handel mit dem holz des
schwarzwaldes rheinabwärts bis nach
holland aus wackelt
[Musik]
vor etwa 100 jahren
so erzählt es wenigstens mainini
war weit und breit kein ehrlicher erfolg
auf erden als die schwarzwälder
jetzt seid so viel geld im land es sind
die menschen unredlich und schlicht
die jungen burschen tanzen und johlen am
sonntag und fluchen dass es ein
schrecken ist
damals war es aber anders
und wenn er jetzt zum fenster dort
herein schaute so sagte ich so oft
gesagt der holländer michel ist schuld
an all dieser verdammnis
es lebte also vor 100 jahren und
darüber ein reicher holzherr der viel
gesinnt hatte er handelte bis weit in
den reihen hin hat und sein geschäft war
gesegnet denn er war ein frommer mann
kommt eines abends ein mann an seiner
tür der gleichen er noch nie gesehen
seine kleidung war wie der schwarzwälder
bursche aber er war einen guten kopf
höher als alle und man hatte noch nie
geglaubt dass es einen solchen riesen
geben könne
dieser bittet um arbeit bei dem konzern
und der holz erde im ansatz sehr stark
und rosen lasten tüchtig sei rechnet mit
ihm seinen lohn und sie schlagen ein
der michel war ein arbeiter wie selbige
holzherr noch keinen gehabt bei einem
baum schlagen galt er
und wenn sechs an einem entschlossen
trug er allein das andere
als er aber ein halbjahr holz geschlagen
hatte eines tages vor seinem herrn und
begehrte von ihm hab jetzt lange genug
hier holz gehackt und so möchte ich auch
sehen wohin seine stimme kommen und wie
wäre es wenn
er mich auch mal auf dem floß ließe
der holzer antwortete
ich will dir nicht im weg sein wenn du
ein wenig hinaus willst in die welt und
zwar beim holzfällen brauche ich starke
leute wie du bist auf dem floss aber
kommt es auf geschicklichkeit an aber
für dieses mal
und so war es
der floss mit dem er ab gehen sollte
hatte acht gleich acht lieder und waren
im letzten von den größten zimmer balken
aber was geschah am abend zuvor bringt
der lange michael noch acht balken ans
wasser so dick und lang als man keinen
je sah und jeden trug er so leicht auf
der schulter wie eine flöte zur stange
so dass ich alles entsetzt
wo er sie gehauen weiß bis heute noch
niemand
dem holz herren lacht das herz also die
ich sah dann aber rechnete was diese
balken kosten könnten mission aber sagte
so die sind für mich zum fahren auf den
kleinen spielen dort kann ich nicht
fortkommen sein er wollte ihm zum dank
ein paar stiefel schinken aber er warf
sie auf die seite und brachte ein paar
vor wie es sonst noch keine gab mein
großvater hat versichert sie haben 100
pfund gewogen und seinen fünf fuß lang
gewesen
der floss ab
und hat er mich als früher die holzhauer
in verwunderung gesetzt so staunten
jetzt die flitzer denn statt das der
floss wie man wegen der ungeheuren
balken geglaubt hatte langsam auf dem
fluss ging flog er sobald sie in den
neckar kamen wie ein pfeil machte der
neckar in der wendung und hatten sonst
die flöte mühe gehabt den floss in der
mitte zu halten und nicht auf kies oder
sand zu stoßen so sprang jetzt der
michel alle mal ins wasser rückte mit
einem zug den floss links oder rechts so
dass er ohne gefahr vorüber geht
und kamen dann eine gerade stelle so
lief er aus erste steuer gelenk vor
dies alle ihre stangen besetzen steckte
seinen ungeheuren weber baum ins kies
und mit einem druck flog der floss dahin
dass das land und bäume unter vorbei zu
jagen stehen
so waren sie in der hälfte der zeit die
man sonst brauchte nach köln am rhein
gekommen wo sie sonst ihre ladung
verkauft hatten aber hier sprach mich
ihr seid mir rechte kaufleute und
verstehen eure nutzen meint ihr denn die
kölner brauchen all dies holz das aus
dem schwarzwald könnt für sich nein um
den halben wert kaufen sie es euch ab
und verhandeln ist euer nach holland
lasset uns die kleinen banken hier
verkaufen und mit den großen nach
holland gehen was wir über den
gewöhnlichen preis lösen ist unsere
eigene profit
so sprach der art lästige michel und die
anderen war es zu schlägen die einen
weil sie gerne nach holland gezogen
wären es zu sehen die anderen das geld
deswegen nur ein einziger war redlich
und mahnte sie ab dass gute ihres herrn
der gefahr auszusetzen oder ihn um den
höheren preis zu betrügen
aber sie hörten nicht auf ihn und
vergaßen seine worte aber der holländer
michel vergaß sie nicht
sie fuhren auch mit dem holz den rhein
hinab michel leitete den flaschen und
brachte sie schnell bis nach rotterdam
dort bot man ihnen das vierfache von den
früheren preis und besonders die
ungeheuren balken des michel wurden mit
schweren geld bezahlt
als die schwarzwälder so viel geld sahen
wussten sie sich vor freude nicht zu
fassen michel teilte ab einen teil im
holz herrn die drei anderen unter die
männer
und nun setzen sie sich mit matrosen und
anderen schlechten gesindel in die
wirtshäuser verschleppten und
verspielten ihr geld dem braven mann
aber der ihnen abgeraten
verkaufte der holländer michel an einen
segeln verkäufer und man hat nichts mehr
von ihm gehört
von da an war dem burschen im
schwarzwald holland das paradies und
rolle in der michael könig
die holz jahren erfuhren lange nichts
von dem handel und unvermerkt kam geld
flüchten kassetten trunk und spiel aus
holland darauf
der holländer michel war aber als die
geschichte heraus kam nirgends zu finden
aber tot ist er auch nicht seit 100
jahren diesen spuk im wald und man sagt
das schon vielen behilflich gewesen sein
reich zu werden aber
[Musik]
auf kosten ihrer armen seele und mehr
will ich nicht sagen aber
so viel ist gewiss dass er noch jetzt in
solchen sturm nächten im tannen bühne wo
man nicht hauen soll
überall die schönsten tannen aussucht
und mein vater hat ihnen eine
vielschichtige umbrechen sehen wie ein
rohr mit
diesen beschenkt er die welche sich vom
rechten abwenden und zu ihm gehen
um mitternacht bringen sie dann die
steine ins wasser und der rudert mit
ihnen nach urlaub aber
wäre ich herr und könig in holland ich
ließ ihn mit karten in den boden
schmettern denn alle schiffe die von dem
holländer michel auch nur einen balken
haben müssen untergehen
daher kommt es dass nur so viel von
schiffbrüchigen hört
wie könnte denn sonst ein schönes
starkes schiff so groß als eine kirche
zu grund gehen auf dem wasser aber
so oft holländer michel in einer
sturmnacht im schwarzwald eine tanne
feld
springt eine seiner alten aus den fugen
des schiffes das wasser trinkt ein oder
schiffes mit mann und maus verloren
das ist die sage um holländer michel
und wahr ist dass alles böse im
schwarzwald schreibt sich von ihm er
er kann einen reich machen setzte der
kreis geheimnisvoll hinzu aber ich
möchte nichts von ihm haben ich möchte
um keinen preis in der haut ist dicke
nähte jeder und des langen stürmers
stecken auch der tanzboden könig soll
sich ihm ergeben haben
der sturm hatte sich während der
erzählung des alten gelegt
die mädchen zündeten schüchtern die
lampen an und gingen weg die männer aber
legten peter munk einen sack voll laub
als kopfkissen auf die ofenbank
und wünschen ihm gute nacht
kohlen mutter hatte noch nie so schwere
träume gehabt wie in dieser nacht
ging weit und tief innen
aber dennoch war es zu peters
verwunderung nicht dunkler im gegenteil
die tages helle schien sogar zuzunehmen
in der flut in der schlucht aber er
konnte sie lange in den augen nicht
ertragen der holländer michel hatte sich
die weiter peter herab kam wieder
kleiner gemacht und stand nun in seiner
früheren gestalt vor einem haus zu
geringe oder gut als reiche bauern aus
dem schwarzwald haben die stube wo rein
peter geführt wurde unterschied sich
durch nichts von den sturm anderer leute
als dadurch dass sie einsam schien
die hölzerne wanduhr der ungeheure
kachelofen die breiten bänke die
gerätschaft noch den gesimsen waren hier
wie überall
michel wies ihm einen platz hinter dem
großen zuschauern ging dann hinaus und
kann bald mit einem klein und gläsern
wieder sehr groß ein und nun schwatzen
sie und tolle länder mich erzählte von
den freuden der welt von fremden ländern
schönen städten und flüssen dass peter
am ende große sehnsucht danach bekommen
dies auch offen den holländer erzählte
wenn du im ganzen körper
mut und kraft etwas zu unternehmen
hattest
da konnten ein paar schräge des dummen
herzens dich zittern machen und dann die
kränkungen der ehre das unglück für was
soll sich ein vernünftiger kerl und
dergleichen bekümmern
hast du es im kopf empfunden als die ich
letzthin eine einen betrüger und
schlechten kern nannte hat es dem magen
wehgetan als der amtmann kam dich aus
dem haus zu werfen was
sagen
was hat dir weh getan
mein herz sprach meter in dem er die
hand auf die wochen der brust legte denn
es war ihm
als ob sein herz ich ängstlich hin und
her wende
du hast nimm mir nicht übel du hast
viele hundert kunden als schlechte
wetter und anderes gesindel weggeworfen
was hat es dich genutzt sie hatten dir
dafür sehen und einen gesunden leib
gewünscht ja du bist deswegen gesünder
geworden um die hälfte verschleuderten
geldes hättest du einen arzt gehalten
sägen ja ein schöner segen wenn man
ausgeblendet und ausgestoßen wird
und das war es was dich getrieben in die
tasche zu fahren so oft ein bettelmann
seinen zerlumpten hut hin streckte dein
herz auch wieder dein herz und wieder
deine augen noch deine zunge der name
noch deine beine sondern dein herz
du hast es dir wie man so richtig sagt
zu sehr zu herzen genommen
aber wie kann man muss sich daran
gewöhnen dass es nicht mehr so ist
ich gebe mir jetzt alle mühe zu
unterdrücken und dennoch pocht mein herz
und tut mir weh
tut freilich rief jena mit lachen du
armer schelm kannst nichts dagegen tun
aber gib mir das kaum pochende ding und
du wirst sehen wie gut du es dann hast
mein herz schrieb liter mit den sätzen
der müsste ich ja sterben auf der stelle
immer mehr
wenn ihr eine eurer herzchirurgen das
herz aus dem leib operieren wollte da
müsstest du wohl stellen bei mir ist
dieser ein anderer dinge doch komm
herein und überzeugt euch selbst
er stammt bei diesen worten auf öffnete
eine kammer tür und führte peter rein
sein herz zog sich krampfhaft zusammen
als er über die schwelle trat aber
erachtete es nicht
denn der anblick der sich ihm bot fahrer
sonderbaren überraschend
auf mehreren gesimsen von holz standen
gläser mit durchsichtiger flüssigkeit
gefüllt und in jedem dieser gläser lag
ein herz auch waren an den gläsern
zettel angeklebt und namen drauf
geschrieben die peter neugierig lars da
war das herz des amtmann cms das herz
dass die gc fiel das herz des tanzboden
königs das herz des oberförster da waren
sechs herzen von kochen bucherer nacht
von vera profitieren drei von geld
metern
kurz
ist eine sammlung der angesehensten
herzen in der umgebung von 20 stunden
sprachen der mich diese aller haben des
lebens ängste und sorgen weggeworfen
keines dieser herzen schlägt mehr
ängstlich und besorgt und ihre
ehemaligen besitzer befinden sich wohl
dabei dass sie den unruhigen gast aus
dem hause haben
aber was tragen muss sie denn jetzt
dafür in der brust fragte peter den dies
alles was er gesehen beinahe schwindeln
machte
dies
antwortete jena und rechte ihm aus einem
schubfach
einstein anders
so
erwiderte er und konnte sich eines
schauers der ihm über die haut gingen
nicht erwehren ein herz von marler stern
aber hab ich einmal herr holländer
michel das muss doch gar kalt sein in
der brust
freilich aber ganz angenehm kühl
warum sollten ein herz warm sein
im winter nützlich die wärme nichts da
hilft ein guter kirche ist mehr als ein
warmes herz und im sommer wenn alles
schwül und heiß ist du glaubst ja nicht
wie dann soll sie ein herz abkühlt und
wie gesagt weder angst noch schrecken
wieder höre ich das mitleiden noch
andere jammern ort an solch ein herz
und das ist alles was er mir geben
könnte fragte peter und mutig ich hoffe
auf geld und ihr wollt mir einen stein
geben
nur ich denke an die 100.000 kunden
hättest du das erste genug wenn du es
geschickt um treibst kannst du bald ein
millionär werden
1000 griff der arme kühler freudig nun
zu pocher doch nicht zu ungestümen
männerbrust wir werden bald fertig sein
miteinander gut michel gebt mir den
stein und das geld und die unruh könnt
ihr aus dem gehäuse nehmen
ich dachte es doch dass du ein
vernünftiger porsche sei
antwortete der holländer freundlich
lächelnd kommen da sonst noch ein streng
und dann legte das geld auszuzahlen
so setzten sie sich wieder in die spur
zum wein
tranken und dann wieder
später in tiefen schlaf so viel
kohle peter erwachte beim fröhlichen
schmettern eines musters und siehe da er
saß in einem schönen wagen fuhr auf
einer breiten straße dahin und als er
sich aus dem wagen bog sah er in blauer
ferne hinter sich den schwarzwald liegen
anfänglich wollte es gar nicht glauben
dass er selber es sei der in diesem
wagen sitzen denn auch seine kleider
waren gar nicht mehr dieselben die er
gestern getragen aber
erinnerte sich doch an alles so deutlich
dass endlich sei nach seinen aufgaben
und rief der kohlen und peter bin ich
das ist ausgemacht und kein anderer
sie haben uns gehört wieder diese frage
wer bin ich eigentlich und wieder eine
antwort die man bezweifeln kann ich
später nun ohne herbst tatsächlich noch
der alte oder ist er der künftige
industrielle durch den herzens tausch
nicht überhaupt aus zu sich selbst
bekommen zum waren peter
dieser impuls ist deutlich gesetzt die
verlockung ist groß
allerdings war da noch das freundliche
glas männlein dieser waldgeist
verkörpert die andere seite des
wirtschaftens das traditionelle handwerk
der glashütten nur dass peter damit eben
nichts anfangen kann es schnell reich
werden und möglichst ohne mühle
und sie haben eben dieser
verführungsszene gehört die für mich zu
den ganz großen verführung szenen der
weltliteratur gehört
macht peter klar was er von ihm erwarten
darf sich auf ihn einlässt er macht ihm
auch klar dass er dadurch mit der zeit
geht alle die in seinem umfeld reich und
mächtig sind verdanken dass dem
holländer mich sie sind sozusagen seine
klienten die glems jüngsten
persönlichkeiten hätten ihr herz an den
holländer mich abgetreten sagte er und
mit der aufgabe des sozialen verhaltens
des herz ist kalt ist aus stein auch
ökonomische fortkommen gesichert ja
überhaupt erst ermöglicht
nachdem herzens tausch
hofft man nur als leser dass peter sowie
er nun wirtschaftet doch nicht der wahre
täter ist der die armen verjagt und in
seiner sinnlosen wut sogar seine frau
lisbeth erschlägt am ende ist es dann
das glas männchen dass es seiner annimmt
und ihm hilft seine echte herz zu
bekommen
[Musik]
du darfst nicht
so schlecht dort ist sprach das männlein
nach einigem nachdenken
aber weil seinen wunsch nicht hörig ist
so kann ich dir wenigstens meine hilfe
nicht abschlagen soleure
dein herz kannst du mit keiner gewalt
mehr bekommen wohl aber durch list
und es wird vielleicht nicht schwer
halten denn michel bleibt doch nur der
dumme michel obgleich er sich ungemein
klug so gehe den geraden weg ist zu ihm
hin und tue wie ich die heiße
und nun unterrichtete er ihnen allem und
gab ihm ein kreuz leiern aus einem glas
am
leben kann er dir nicht schaden und er
wirklich freilassen wenn du ihm dies
vorhalten und dazu bieten wirst und hast
du denn was du verlangt hast erhalten so
kommt wieder zu mir an diesen ort
beton nahm das kreuz leyen
regte sich alle worte ins gedächtnis und
ging weiter nach holländer michels
behausung
lief dreimal seinen namen und alsbald
stand der riese vor ihm
du hast dein weiter schlagen
fragte er ihn mit schrecklichen lachen
hörte ich auch so gemacht sie hat dein
vermögen das metal volk gebracht aber du
wirst darauf einige zeit außer landes
gehen müssen denn es wird lärm machen
wenn man sie nicht findet und
du brauchst um geld und kommst du musst
zu holen
was sollten erwiderte peter und nur
recht viel diesmal denn nach amerika ist
michael wie vor an und brachte ihn in
seine hütte
dort schloss er eine tour aus worin viel
geld lag und gelangte ganze holm gold
heraus
während der so auf den tisch zu tisch
nach meter du bist doch ein loser vogel
michael dass du mich belogen ist ich
hätte einen stein in der brust und du
hast mein herz
und ist es denn nicht so fragte mich
erstaunt fühlst du denn dein herz ist es
nicht kalt wie eis hast du furcht oder
gramm kann dich etwas freuen
du hast mein herz 0 stillstehen lassen
aber ich habe es noch wie sonst in
meiner brust und sie fiel auch der hat
es mir gesagt hast du uns angelogen hast
du bist nicht der mann dazu der einem
das herz so unbemerkt und ohne gefahr
aus der brust reifen könnte da müsstest
du zaubern können
aber ich versichere dich reeves michel
unmut ich du und ich ihnen und all die
reichen leute die ihr mit mir gehalten
haben soll ich kalte herzen wie du und
ihre rechten herzen habe ich hier in
meiner kammer
was du das lügen von der zunge geht
lachte peter das machst du einem anderen
weiß meinst du ich habe auf meinen
reisen nicht solche kunststücke zu
dutzenden gesehen auswachsen nachgeahmt
sind dein herzen hier in der kammer du
bist ein reicher kerl das gebe ich zu
aber zaubern kannst du nicht
da krümmte der riese ist die kammer
thürauf
komme ein und ließ die zettel hallo und
jenes der schau das ist peter max herz
siehst du jetzt
kann man das auch aus wachs machen
und doch ist es aus wachs antwortete
peter
so schlägt ein recht das herz nicht ich
habe dass meine knochen der brust nach
hinzaubern kannst du nicht aber ich will
es mir beweisen rief ihn ärgerlich du
sollst dir selbst führen dass dies dein
herz ist
der name des petersdoms auf und nahmen
stein aus seiner brust und zeigte ihnen
vor dann nahm er das herz tauchte es an
und setzte es behutsam an seiner stelle
und alsbald fühlte peter wie es pochte
und er könnte sich wieder darüber freuen
wie ist es dir jetzt
fragte mich lächelnd
warte ich das doch recht gehabt
antwortete peter indem er behutsam sein
kreuz seien aus der tasche zog
hätte ich doch nicht glauben dass man
dergleichen tun könne nicht wahr
und
zaubern kann ich das siehst du aber
kommen jetzt will ich dir den stein
wieder hinein setzen gemacht
später trat einen schritt zurück und
hielt in das kreuz land entgegen mit
speck fängt man mäuse um diesmal bist du
der betrogene und
zugleich finger anzubieten was ihm nur
beispiele
da wurde michael kleiner und immer
kleiner viele nieder und wann sich hin
und her wie ein wurm und ächzte und
stöhnte und alle herzen her fingen an zu
zucken zu pochen dass es tönte wie in
der werkstatt eines uhrenmacher
peter befürchtet es wird ihm ganz
unheimlich zumute er rannte zur kammer
und zum haus hinauf und klemmte von
angst getrieben die felswand ihnen denn
er hörte dass michael sich aufraffte
stampfte und tobte und dem schreck
welche flüche nach schickte
also oben war
rief er den handel zu ein schreckliches
wetter zog auf blitze vielen links und
rechts an die nidda zerschmetterten die
bäume aber er kam wohlbehalten
im revier des glas im inland an
sein herz pochte freudig und nur darum
weil es kochte
dann aber sogar mit entsetzen auf sein
leben zurück wie auf das gewitter das
hinter ihm rechts und links den schönen
wald zersplitterte
er dachte an frau lisbeth sein schönes
gutes weil das aus geiz gemordet er kann
sich selbst wieder auswurf der menschen
vor und er weinte heftig als er an gras
männlein zügel kam
schatz hauser saß schon unter dem
tannenbaum und rauchte aus einer kleinen
doch da er munter aus als zuvor
warum weinst du später fragte hast du
dein herz nicht erhalten liegt noch das
kalte in deiner brust
ach ja
später als ich noch das kalte herz druck
da meinte ich nie meine augen waren so
trocken als das land im juli jetzt aber
wenn es mir beinahe das alte herz
zerbrechen was ich getan habe
keine schulden habe ich ins elend gejagt
auf arme und kranke die hunde gehetzt
und ihr alle wisst es ja selbst wie
meine peitsche auf ihre schöne stirne
viel
fitter du warst ein großer sender sprach
das männlein das geld und der müßiggang
haben sich verdammt bis dein herz zu
stein wurde nicht freut nicht leid keine
reue kein mittelalten erkannte aber
reue versöhnt und wenn ich nur wüsste
dass dir dein leben recht leid tut so
könnte ich schon noch etwas für dich tun
nichts mehr antwortete peter und liest
traurig sein haupt sinken mit mir ist
das aus haben mich mein lebtag nicht
mehr freuen was soll ich so allein auf
der welt tun meine mutter verzeiht man
immer was ich ihr getan und vielleicht
habe ich sie unter den boden gebracht
ich ungeheuer und lisbeth meine frau
fragen mich lieber auch tod herrscher zu
hause dann hat mein elend leben mit
einmal ein ende
erwiderte dass männlein wenn du nicht
anders willst du kannst du sagen magst
habe ich bei der hand
einnahmen ganz ruhig sein zeiss leyen
aus dem mund klopfte es aus und steckt
es ein
dann stand er langsam auf und ging
hinter die tannen
peter aber setzte sich weinend ins gras
sein leben war ihm nichts mehr und da
erwartete geduldig den todes streichen
nach einiger zeit wird der leise dritte
hinter sich und dachte jetzt willkommen
schau dich noch einmal um peter rief das
männlein er wischte sich die tränen aus
den augen und schaute sich um und sah
seine mutter und ließ plätze eine frau
die ihn freundlich an blickten
da strenger freudig auf so bist du nicht
tot lisbeth und auch ihr seid da mutter
und hat mir vergeben
sie wollen dir verzeihen sprach das glas
männlein weil du ware reue fühlst und
alles unvergessen sind
sie jetzt heim in deines vaters schütte
und seinen kühler wie zuvor
bist du brav und bieder
so wirst du dein handwerk ehren und
deine nachbarn werden dich mehr lieben
und achten als wenn du zehn tonnen
goldes hättest
so sprach das glas männern
und nahm abschied von ihnen
äußerst erbaulich und nun
natürlich konnten die gebildeten stände
aufatmen und brauche sich keine sorgen
um löcher zu machen das märchen geht gut
aus peter bekommt im herbst zurück und
selbst seine ehefrau steht von den toten
wieder auf doch dieser letzte teil des
märchen ist so erkennbar ohne jede
rücksicht auf die dem test eigene logik
verfasst das eher wie eine moralische
pflicht über wirkt man mag mit fug und
recht daran zweifeln dass peter sein
herbst tatsächlich zurück erlangt hat
und kommt dann um eine andere botschaft
des märchens nicht mehr herum die neue
zeit mit ihrer neuen wirtschaftsform
hält kein glas männern auf wer sich
einmal auf sie eingelassen hat kann sich
kaum wieder in die traditionelle
lebensweise früherer generationen fügen
und er wird es auch nicht wollen
allerdings ist kauf es bergauf eine
andere tendenz ablesbar ein fingerzeig
darauf wie wir uns zumindest die
möglichkeit
erhalten unserem weg in einer maschine
seligen zeit selbst zu wählen
es ist eng mit der zeitgenössischen
publizistik verbunden die freie rede das
freie wort kauf verhandelt das auffällig
gern vor dem hintergrund eines
imaginierten orients geprägt von
absoluter herrscher macht und
drakonischen strafen aber auch von jeher
umschlungen wer heute als kalif ganz
oben ist kann sich plötzlich als
machtloser stoß wiederfinden dann
nämlich wenn er seine sprache verliert
[Musik]
der kalif von bagdad sei es einmal an
einen schönen nachmittag behaglich auf
seinem sofa aber dann bin ich das
schlafen denn es war ein heißer tag
und sah nun nach seinem schläfchen recht
heiter aus
rauch der aus einer langen teil von
rosenholz
franchi und da ein wenig kaffee den ihm
ein sklave einschenkte und strich sich
allemal vergnügen bad wenn es ihm
geschmeckt hatte
kurz man sah dem kalifen an dass es ihm
recht wohl wahr
um diese stunde konnte man gut mit ihm
reden weil er da immer recht mild und
leutselig war deswegen besuchte ihn auch
sein großwesir man so alle tage um diese
zeit
an diesem nachmittag kam auch sei aber
sehr nachdenklich aus ganz gegen seine
gewohnheit der kalif hat die pfeife ein
wenig aus dem mund und sprach vom machst
du ein nachdenkliches gesicht großwesir
der großwesir schlug seine arme
kreuzweise über die brust verneigte sich
vor seinem herrn und antwortete herr
ob ich ein nachdenkliches gesicht mache
weiß ich nicht aber da drunten am
schluss steht ein krämer der hat so
schöne sachen dass es mich ärgert nicht
viel überflüssiges geld zu haben
der kalif der seinen großwesir schon
lange gerne eine freude gemacht hätte
schickte seinen schwarzen sklaven
hinunter und in krämer herauszuholen
bald kam der sklave mit dem thema zurück
dieser war ein kleiner dicker mann
schwarz braun im gesicht und in
zerlumpten
anzug trug einen kasten in welchem er
allerhand waren hatte perlen und ringe
reichen beschlagenen pistolen becher und
käme
der kalif und sein visier mussten alles
durch und der kalif kaufte endlich für
sich und man so schöne pistolen für die
frau des risikos aber entkam
als der krämer seinen kasten schon
wieder zu machen wollte sagt der kalif
eine kleine schubladen und fragte ob da
auch noch waren seien der krämer zog die
schublade heraus und zeigte darin eine
dose mit schwärzlichen pulver und ein
papier mit sonderbarer schrift die
wieder der kalifen ochmann so lesen
konnten
ich bekam einmal diese zwei stücke einen
kaufmann der sie in mekka auf der straße
fand sagte der krämer ich weiß nicht was
sie enthalten euch stehen sie um
geringen preis zu diensten ich kann doch
nichts damit anfangen
der kalif der in seiner bibliothek gerne
alte manuskripte hatte wenn er sie auch
nicht lesen konnte kaufte schrift und
dose und entließ den krämer der kalif
aber dachte er möchte gerne wissen was
die schrift enthalte
und fragte den wir sie ob er keinen
kennen der es entziffern könnte
nächste herr und gebieter
antwortete dieser an der großen moschee
wohnt ein mann er heißt selim der
gelehrte der versteht alle sprachen
dass ihnen kommen vielleicht kennt er
die geheimnisvollen züge
defilierte selim walter bei brot
selim
sprach zu in der kalifen sehen im ansatz
ist sehr gelehrt cook einmal ein wenig
in dieser schrift ob du sie lesen kannst
kannst du sie lesen so bekommst du ein
neues fest leid von mir kannst du es
nicht so bekommst du zwölf packten
streiche und 25 die vorschulen weil man
dich dann umsonst selim den gelehrten
nennt
selim verneigt er sich uns mal dein
wille geschehe wo er
lange betrachtete die schrift
plötzlich lief aus das ist lateinisch
oder her oder ich lass mich hängen
sagt was drinsteht befall der kalif wenn
es lateinisch ist
selim fing an zu übersetzen
mensch der du dieses findest preise
allah für seine gnade wer von dem pulver
in dieser pose schlüpft und dazu spricht
mutabor
der kann sich in jedes tier verwandeln
und versteht auch die sprache der tiere
will er wieder in seine menschliche
gestalt zurückkehren so neige er sich
dreimal den osten und spreche jenes wort
aber hüte dich wenn du verwandelt bist
dass du nicht lachst sonst verschwindet
das zauberwort gänzlich aus seinem
gedächtnis und du bleibst ein tier
als sehlem der gelehrte also gelesen
hatte war der kalif über die maßen
vergnügt er ließ ihn stören niemand
etwas von dem geheimnis zu sagen
schenkte ihm ein schönes kleid und
entließ ihn zu seinem groß wie sie aber
sagte er dass ich gut einkaufen man so
wie freue ich mich dass ich ein tier bin
morgen früh kommst du zu mir wir gehen
dann miteinander auch schnupfen etwas
weniger ist aus meiner dose und
belauschen dann was in der luft und im
wasser im wald und feld gesprochen
kaum hatte am anderen morgen der khalifa
sieht gefrühstückt und sich an gekleidet
als schon der großwesir erschien wir
befohlen hatte auf dem spaziergang zu
begleiten der kalif steckte die dose mit
dem zauber pulver in den gürtel und
nachdem er seinem gefolge befohlen hatte
zurückzubleiben machte sich mit dem
großwesir ganz allein auf den weg
sie gingen zuerst durch die beiden
gärten des kalifen späten aber vergebens
nach etwas leben um ihre kunst stück zu
probieren
der wesir schlug endlich vor weiter
hinaus an einem teich zu gehen wo er
schon oft viele tiere
namentlich storch gesehen habe die durch
ihre gravitätische wesen und ihre klappe
immer seine aufmerksamkeit erregt hatte
der kalif billigte den vorschlag seines
visiers und ging mit ihm dem track zu
als sie dort angekommen waren sagen sie
einen storchen
ernsthaft auf und ab gehen frösche
suchen um sie und da etwas vor sich hin
klappernd zugleich sahen sie auch weit
oben in der luft einen anderen starken
diese gegend zu schweben
ich wette meinen bart manager heldt
sagte gross lässt wenn nicht diese zwei
lang füße ein schönes gespräch
miteinander führen werden wie wäre es
wenn wir störche würden
wohl gesprochen
antwortete der kalif aber vorher wollen
wir noch einmal betrachten wie man
wieder menschlich richtig drei mal gen
osten geneigt und
mutabor gesagt so bin ich wieder tarif
und du visier aber nur um himmels willen
nicht gelacht sonst sind wir verloren
während der kalif also sprach da er den
anderen stoffen über ihrem haupt
geschrieben und langsam sich zu ehren
lassen
schnell zog er die dose aus dem gürtel
nahm eine gute prise bot sie dem
großwesir da der gleichfalls schmückte
und briefen mutabor
da schrumpften ihre beine ein und wurden
dünn und hut die schönen gelben dann
doppel des kalifen und seines begleiters
wurden um förmliche storch füße die arme
wurden zu flügeln der hals fuhr aus den
achseln und waadt eine elle lang der
bart war verschwunden und den körper
bedeckten weiche wie wirr
wir haben einen hübschen schnabel herr
gross frisieren sprach nach langem
erstaunen der kalif beim barte des
propheten so etwas habe ich in meinem
leben noch nicht gesehen
danke untertänigst erwiderte der
großwesir indem er sich bückte aber wenn
ich es wagen darf zu behaupten eure
hoheit zeigen sehen als storch beinah
noch hübscher aus denn als khalifa kommt
wenn es euch gefällig ist dass wir
unsere kameraden dort belauschen fahren
ob wir wirklich storch können
indem wir der andere ständig auf der
erde angekommen
er putzt du sich mit dem schnabel seine
füße legt er seine federn zurecht und
ging auf den ersten staatlichen zu
die beiden neuen störche aber beeilten
sich in ihrer nähe zu kommen
und vernahmen zu ihrem erstaunen
folgendes gespräch
und morgen frau langbein so früh schon
auf der wiese
schönen dank liebe klapper schreibe ich
habe nur ein kleines frühstück
ist euch vielleicht einen wirklichen
ityx gefährlich oder ein froschschenkel
ein
danke gehorsamst aber heute gar keinen
appetit ich komme auch wegen etwas ganz
anderem auf die wiese ich soll heute vor
den gästen meines vaters tanzen und da
will ich mich im stillen ein wenig üben
zugleich schützt die junge störrischen
wunderlichen bewegungen durch das feld
der kalif und man so sagen ihr
verwundert nach als sie aber in
malerischer stellung auf einem fuß stand
und mit den flügeln anmutig dazu wedelte
da konnten sich die beiden nicht mehr
halten eine unaufhaltsame schlechter
brach aus ihren schnäbeln hervor und dem
sie sich erst nach langer zeit erholten
der kalli fasste sich zuerst wieder das
war einmal ein spaß rief er der nicht
mit geld zu bezahlen ist schade dass die
dummen tiere durch unser gelächter sich
haben verscheuchen lassen sonst hätten
sie vielleicht auch noch gesungen
[Musik]
aber jetzt fiel es dem gros visier ein
dass das lachen während der verwandlung
verboten war
heute sind angst deswegen dem kalifen
mit
uns mekka und medina
das wäre ein schlechter spaß wenn ich
ein storch bleiben musste die sinne dich
doch auf das dumme war ich bringe es
nicht haus
drei mal gen osten müssen wir uns
brücken und dazu sprechen
sie stellten sich gegen osten und
bückten sich in einem fort dass ihre
schnäbel beinahe die erde berühren aber
jammern
das zauberwort war ihnen entfallen und
so oft sich auch der kalif bückte so
sehnlich auch sein visier
dazu rief
jede erinnerung daran war sie schon
und der armee sieht und sein visier
blieben stehen
dass die welt zu singen anfängt triffst
du nur das zauberwort nicht erst seit
eichendorff die feste überzeugung der
mit den romantikern aufgewachsene
generation aber wenn man das wort nun
nicht trifft wenn man nur
stottern kann wie der verzauberte kalif
und befürchten muss ewig im falschen
körper ein falsches leben zu führen das
wort mutabor das verwandlung verhallt
erweist sich als sprengsatz in einer
ständigen ordnung ein sprengsatz auch
für die stellung des kalifen dann ist
eine plötzliche hilflosigkeit ist ja ein
zeichen dafür wie rasch
herrschaftsstrukturen es banken raten
können
aber auch für jeden einzelnen ist
mutabor ein zauberwort ein
aufbruchsignal in der nur scheinbar
friedlichen in mancher hinsicht geradezu
umstürzlerischen biedermeierzeit
das passte nicht jedem und der gewaltige
überwachungsapparat verbunden mit dem
namen metternich der in dieser zeit
aktiv war spricht bände
das ist die freie rede ist die den
menschen frei macht an welchem ort und
in welcher lage auch immer davon wird
auch nicht müde zu erzählen und wenn in
seinem ersten märchen einmal nach die
karawane als motiv für die eingestreuten
geschichten die langeweile der reisenden
genannt wird avanciert das erzählen im
dritten mal nach das wirtshaus im
spessart so zieren überlebensstrategie
nur wenn die gesellschaft den der
spelunke mitten im wald zusammengekommen
ist geschlossen wach bleibt besteht die
chance dem angriff der räuber etwas
entgegen zu setzen und um wach zu
bleiben erzählt man sich geschichten
im scheich von alessandra aber auf
zweite märchen einmal nach dessen erster
geschichte zwerg nase ist gibt der
damals 23 jahre alte autor den
allerbesten grund dafür an warum wir
einander von uns und der welt erzählen
sondern
gut
aber hat nicht der vorleser nicht
freunde genug warum ist es gerade diese
sklaven seien die erzählen
die sklaven lieberherr sagte hatte
sind vermutlich durch allerlei unglück
in sklaverei geraten und sind nicht
gerade so ungebildete leute wie ihr wohl
gesehen habt von welchen man sich nicht
könne erzählen lassen überdies stammen
sie von allerlei ländern und völkern und
es ist zu erwarten dass sie bei sich zu
hause irgendetwas merkwürdiges
gehört oder gesehen dass sie nun zu
erzählen wissen
einen noch schöneren grund den mir einst
ein freund des sheikh sagte will ich
euch wieder geben
diese leute waren es jetzt in seinem
hause als laden
hatten sie auch keine schwere arbeit zu
verrichten so war es doch immer arbeit
zu der sie gezwungen waren und mächtig
der unterschied zwischen ihnen und
freien leuten sie durften sich wir sitte
ist dem schalk nicht anders als mit den
zeichen der unterwürfigkeit nähern
sie durften nicht zu ihm reden außer er
fragte sie und ihre rede musste kurz
sein
heute sind sie frei und
ihr erstes geschäft als freie leute ist
in großer gesellschaft und vor ihren
bisherigen herren lange und offen
sprechen zu dürfen
sie fühlen sich nicht wenig geehrt durch
und ihre unverhoffte freilassung
wird ihnen dadurch nur umso härter
wer frei spricht trägt keine fesseln
mehr noch wer gut erzählt und daraus wie
auf einen beruf macht dem einer
auskömmliches dasein beschert für den es
die freie rede auch in dieser hinsicht
eine lebensnotwendigkeit und für uns
alle anderen auch vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]